this video has been years in the making
actually I'm quite excited about this
video it's a problem that I'm actually
got a part in as well I've been given
permission to give you an exclusive look
at this new solution it's a secret it's
not a secret I'm going to tell you all
so in this box we have our new solution
to this old problem and building up to
this I think I should start with what
the problem is of course imagine four
friends and they're going to play a game
and they want to decide who goes first
second third and fourth fine so to do
that they decide to roll dice they roll
one each and whoever has the highest
number goes first second highest number
goes second you get the idea the only
problem with that is two players might
roll the same number oh no a draw so
what are they going to do they could
roll again well potentially that could
go on forever is there a set of four
dice so each player can have one roll
them together there are no drawers and
all equally likely to be first second
third and fourth that's the question
well that does exist they're called go
first dice they were invented by Eric
carsparger and Robert Ford about 10
years ago I've got these actually so
here they are so these are four
12-sided dice they use the numbers from
1 to 48 so there's no repeats so you're
not going to get a draw that's easily
solved and they've been designed so that
you're equally likely to be first second
third and fourth very nice
as a bonus though it also works for
subsets so if you had three friends they
could pick any three of these Dice and
that would do the same thing they would
be equally likely to be first second and
third
or if you have two friends they could
pick any two of these dice
and you'd be equally likely to be first
and second really nice so the question
then was What's it gonna look like for
five players can we make a set of five
dice no drawers and you're equally
likely to be first second third fourth
and fifth that's the question we've got
a new solution for but before I show you
that new solution I want to show you the
best answers we've had so far just to
build up to this the first one I want to
show you is one of my own okay I get to
do this my video I can do that right
yeah okay I don't know what you imagine
it's going to look like but this is it
so this is a set of 5 60 sided dice
they're using the numbers one to three
hundred and just like they're supposed
to you roll them you're equally likely
to be first second third fourth and
fifth
works for the subsets as well so that's
kind of nice so there you go I can just
see the number you see I should have
painted in the numbers couldn't be
bothered couldn't be bothered so this is
my solution I came up with this uh years
ago not to be confused by the way with
things like non-transitive dice or other
things you may have seen before you know
it sounds similar but it is a different
problem this is a different solution to
that so this is kind of nice I I might
tell you a little bit about how we came
across it so I did this with an internet
friend of mine Brian Pollock and well we
did a computer search but just to do a
computer search would take a long time
if you search through every possible set
of five dice it's just a huge number
we're talking like many many many
Googles of possibilities right too many
to search through
so we did a clever search uh so what we
did is we looked for dice with a
particular nice mathematical structure
and that allowed us to reject the wrong
answers really quickly so we sort of
narrowed our search down to these
particularly nice kind of dice so you
could reject the wrong ones easily then
the ones you can't reject we checked
that's what we did and that's what we
found we found the 60-sided dice we knew
that the answer they're all the same
size like these are we knew that the
dice were going to be
30-sided or a multiple of 30.
we didn't find 30-sided dice but we did
find these 60
sided dice so that's nice I was proud of
this this is my solution to it we can do
better though because this solution
you're equally likely to be first second
third fourth and fifth
what about if we make every order of the
players equally likely so a b c d e is
just as likely as e d c b a
that might sound like the same thing
that's what I thought when I said is it
every order equally likely or every
place equally likely as in who gets the
highest second highest yeah number right
yeah I thought that isn't that the same
so no having every order is actually a
stronger sense of fairness this set that
I discovered every place is equally
likely you're equally likely to be first
second third fourth and fifth every
order is not equally likely with this in
fact they're a b c d e is less likely
than edcba with this set quick question
yeah is every what about with these ones
every order is equally likely it's
something we appreciated slightly after
the fact okay okay but should we make it
every order equally likely yeah so
that's a downfall of those I'm like I
said I you know we came up with this
idea I'm quite proud of it but can we
make an even better set every order
equally likely that would be nice uh now
the original inventors of the go first
dice that's Eric and Robert they came up
with a solution put my set to one side
I'll show you Eric's solution yeah
yes special box for it yeah well they
look like this oh
yeah that's the right reaction you
answered my next question actually
because the dice all have the same
number of sides so if you relax that
condition here is a set with all weird
sides so they're not all the same number
of sides but this is every order
equally likely we've got a 20-sided dice
here we've got a 36 sided dice here
we've got two 48s and we've got a 54
sided dice so this is what we've got
they're all kind of weird values but
every order equally like it and true for
the subsets I might be worth telling you
how these were invented the idea was you
start with a set that you already know
is permutation fare that's what we call
it when all the orders are equally
likely so let's start with a set of
three dice they're going to be six-sided
Dice and they're going to have these
numbers on them so let's say a here is
going to be 2 5 7 12 14 and 17 B I'll do
the B is three four eight eleven
thirteen eighteen and we'll do c which
is one six nine ten fifteen and sixteen
there we go six-sided price but he's in
numbers one to eighteen every order is
equally likely what we can do though is
turn that set of three into a set of
four
so this is this is how you do it what
we're going to do first we're going to
double the size of these dice right so
we're going to repeat it two five seven
twelve fourteen Seventeen I'm trying to
fit them into my piece of paper do that
again and for C okay one six nine ten 15
and 16 and so that we don't repeat the
numbers so we can tell them apart I'm
going to add 100 to the first copy and
200 to the second copy so that now
they're different numbers look I've got
gaps now there are numbers less than 100
that I could use I've got a gap here
between 118 and 201 I could use that Gap
and I've got a gap here larger than 218
so we're going to create a new one
called D we're going to put values in
those gaps and we can calculate how many
values to put in those gaps and keep the
set of dice still permutation fair in
this example if you put one number in
the first Gap could be anything I want I
call it 50. I could put 50 here I could
put four numbers in that second Gap
let's call it 150 and then 151
152 153 there you go and then one number
in that last Gap 250 that will do it
that's now a set of four dice which will
still be permutation Fair we can shrink
those numbers down as well so that it's
all consecutive but now the new one I've
introduced is now six-sided there's no
guarantee that that new die will have
the same number of sides as the other
dice that you started with and that's
why they start to have weird sizes there
are things you can do that you can make
the dice like have the lowest common
multiple of that that I start to get
quite large the size of these dice do
get quite large it doesn't have to be
two copies either sometimes you get a
nicer set of dice if you do like three
copies and then fill those gaps or like
five copies or ten copies sometimes you
just get a nicer result by doing that
instead now those two sets of dice I've
just shown you
were the best answers we had
up to about two months ago and radio I
was going to make this video about two
months ago and that was going to be the
end of the video
just before I came and did that video uh
we were contacted our little team of
dice inventors were contacted by a
mathematician called Michael Purcell and
he said I've got a new solution for you
now I'm going to show you that that's it
that's what I've been building up to no
that's the box that's the box over here
so what is it going to be this is
Michael's solution you ready I'm
trembling with anticipation
right here we go this is
this is it
this is a set of five
sided dice
all the same number of sides which is
nice and every order is equally likely
as well uh so I think this is one of my
favorite sets so far his ideas were
completely different to the ideas that
we were using you started with a set of
five 12-sided dice but they weren't
completely permutation Fair any subset
of four dice did work it was only
partially there what he did next is he
made 10 copies of that kind of like this
method here
so he made those 12 sided dice into 120.
sided dice that doesn't completely solve
it they're still not permutation Fair
what he did next is in the copies he
started to swap the rows over so in the
second copy he swapped the first row and
the third row in the third copy he
swapped the first row and the fifth row
so he started doing some permutations as
we call them on the rows within those
copies that he made by doing that it
kind of balanced out all the sort of
biases all the little problems to sort
of cancel themselves out and the result
was this set of five 120-sided dice
where every order is equally likely the
important thing about that is we kind of
knew you could do something like that
there was a team actually we've got a
YouTube channel as well so I'm going to
give him a little bit of a shout out the
polylog YouTube channel they realized
that if you did every permutation
on the rows that would balance out all
the biases they work that out but if you
do every permutation these are going to
be huge dice
well Michael has done is he found that
you could do it with just 10
permutations not just using every
permutation
and there are some open questions
because he did it with a computer
is there some mathematical reason or
mathematical way to pick the
permutations that balance out all those
biases we're not sure about that we're
still thinking about that you know is is
there a way to pick the initial seed set
of dice that initial set of dice before
we made copies it's a good way to pick
that is there a good way to pick the
permutations
there's still problems we're working on
but yes at least with a computer search
we can use those ideas and we can get
this set of five
120-sided dice
two questions yeah I'm ready all right
first question is I'm not questioning
your motivation for doing this I think
it's really cool but our gopher starts
like necessary is there a demand in The
Gaming Community for go first dice no no
so you can solve this problem in simpler
ways so if I wanted to arrange five
people in some order I would just have
five cards with one two three four five
written on it and then you Shuffle that
up and they can pick a card I mean
that's that's that's not the point
there are easier solutions to this
um another easy solution by the way to
this is you could just have one die with
120 sides on it each side would have an
order of the five people and then roll
that you could do it with one die that's
not the point either that's not fun the
fun is five players have one die each
and they all roll them they all have
something to do and then it orders them
that's the fun part of it and the other
obvious question it Springs to mind is
what about six does
now six yes so Eric uh who originally
invented this and is really like our
boss in all of this uh he has a website
where he's collating all like the best
results uh so for six shall I just so I
just look at what the answer for six is
oh no I'll save that thought actually
can I go back a step cool
there is a second punch line to this uh
video because Michael contacted us with
this new result and we were so excited
by it a little team of dice experts
stop working on it well one in
particular Brown Cohen and he started to
mix and match our methods so he started
to use a bit of Michael's method a bit
of Eric's method started to match them
together uh just to see if he could find
a better solution and this is his
solution uh so I've got another set
this is a set of four
36-sided Dice and one
20-sided dice so it's almost like
they're all the same size so very
similar sizes like oh you're almost all
the same size also the dice are just so
much smaller than than any of these
Solutions we've got so far so if you
were just looking at adding up all the
sides and seeing that you know trying to
minimize that number then in that case
by that measure uh this is the best set
we've found so that's more efficient but
that one there's more perfect because
they're all the same yeah some of us
like to minimize the total number of
sides and some of us like to have them
all the same because it makes it more
like a toy I feel but also minimize that
number as well so for six players
the best results we've got now
um using
actually bram's method uh the best
result we've got a set which is a
20-sided die
and then five
360 sided dice that's quite asymmetrical
yeah yeah yeah one of these and that's
because of how bram's method worked so
he actually used Michael's method to
make these set of dice
and then by induction he created one
extra dice
which is why this one has a different
size to all the other dice so that's why
this is the 20-sided dice there because
it's fitting in the gaps so this is why
it's a mix and match of of these two
methods here
can we do better can we find a smaller
set of dice personally I want to find a
set of 5 30 sided dice theoretically we
can make a set of five thirty sided dice
but they might not exist if they don't
exist can we make a set of Five Sixty
sided dice or maybe this set of dice
here maybe this is kind of minimum in
its way or is it again these are
questions we still don't know the
answers to
this episode's been supported by our
regular and superb sponsor brilliant
makers of these world-class interactive
lessons and courses
I was of course completely unsurprised
to learn they have a lot of stuff
involving dice including some of this
which really dives into the sort of
stuff you've just been watching dice
competing against each other and stuff
like that do make sure you check it out
people whether it's for you or the
Learner in your life I can't think of a
better way to expand your horizons than
a subscription to brilliant they've just
got so much quality material and new
stuff's being added all the time well
designed thoughtful and sometimes quite
funny a bit of personality to it learn
more at brilliant.org number file
they've got a free 30-day trial which is
amazing and using the URL on screen
that's going to get you a 20 discount
off their premium offering there are
links and details in the description
under the video
[Music]
foreign